vamos a conversar con Manuel José
Bermúdez Andrade uno de los viudos de
esta relación y beneficiado con este
fallo y nos explicó Cuál fue el
argumento que convenció finalmente a la
corte para llegar a este fallo histórico
es el argumento es muy simple y es el
amor y es la convivencia la ley exige
techo lecho y mesa y nosotros tuvimos
comprobar que durante 10 años con Alex
los tres los cuatro tuvimos
techo lecho y mesa y mucho amor Entonces
ahí no había ninguna discusión bueno
Asimismo le preguntamos y le parece que
no hay una sintonía entre la apertura de
la ley colombiana para las parejas del
mismo sexo y para las parejas o grupos
amorosos de más de una persona o dos y
la conservadora sociedad colombiana que
piensa él
sí tenemos Incluso un congreso muy
cerrado muy conservador Pero
afortunadamente esto es un asunto legal
es un asunto de la ley constitucional Y
entonces Desde esa perspectiva
independientemente de que la gente le
guste o no todos los logros que hemos
tenido al margen de la Constitución
Perdón al margen de ese congreso godo se
tienen que sostener porque no hay otra
posibilidad distinta de entender que
somos una familia como cualquiera otra
familia Cada persona tiene derecho a
tener una familia esté constituida como
este constituida somos familia así de
simple y entonces se tienen que acomodar
a que es una norma constitucional la
protección de la familia